Madeleine Blais-Morin
est à New York.
GoGoGood morning!
What's the latest on Ukraine?
- Justin Trudeau est de retour
en personne à l'Assemblée
générale de l'ONU après
quatre ans d'absence en raison
d'élections et de la COVID.
Quatre ans pendant lesquels
l'état du monde ne s'est pas
amélioré. Le secrétaire général
prévient que de la grogne
se profile à l'horizon.
"La crise du coût de la vie
fait rage, la confiance
s'effrite, les inégalités
explosent pendant que la planète
brûle." Il dét t t un portrait
sombre de la situation.
La guerre en Ukraine n'est pas
la seule à blâmer.
BOB RAE, ambassadeur du Canada
aux Natiunununies
- C'est une cascade de crises.
C'est aussi la question
de la COVID-19, de l'impact,
comme l'a dit le secrétaire
gél,l,l, l'impact du changement
climatique, une crise globale
qui va durer pour l'avenir.
- Ça ne suffit pas, selon lui,
de décrire les problèmes,
il faut trouver des solutions.
- Les Nations unies,
c'est l'endroit où on discute
et on commence à faire
des changements, on commence
à faire des décisions
pour vraiment retrouver la façon
de répondre aux crises.
- Justin Trudeau montre qu'il
veut agir sur plusieurs fronts.
Il a participé à des sommets
sur la sécurité alimentaire et
sur la lutte contre le contenu
violent en ligne.
C'est la ministre Mélanie Joly
qui doit prononcer le discours
devant l'Assemblée, cette année.
- On doit accorder au dossier de
la biodiversité la même urgence
qu'à celui des changements
climatiques.
La nature oioioit pas être
reléguée en second plan.
- C'est la ministre Mélanie Joly
qui doit prononcer le discours
devant l'Assemblée, cette année.
Ses priorités : l'Ukraine et la
lutte contre la désinformation.
MÉLANIE JOLY, ministre
des Affaires étrangères
- Il va de soi que
la désinformation,
particulièrement celle en ligne,
affecte nos démocraties et
nos institutions démocratiques.
- Justin Trudeau tenait
à participer à l'ouverture
de l'Assemblée générale,
quitte r r rater la rentrée
parlementaire. Les problèmes
discutés ici, du coût de la vie
aux changements climatiques,
se répercutent aussi au pays.
S'il cherche à se présenter
comme un leader sur la scène
internationale, il devra aussi
démontrer que les solutions
qu'il propose aux Canadiens
sont bien pensées.
Ici Madeleine Blais-Morin,
Radio-Canada, New Yor